welcome to other thankful Thursday I
believe is important to think that
people have had an impact on your
business and on your life just reach out
and say thank you because I'm gonna make
you feel better then feel better and
spread some good karma out there in the
world so today I want to thank Kanye
West Kanye West Kanye West now most
people think of Kanye as a obnoxious
rude loudmouth who'll say anything he
needs to get in order to get some
attention they remember him for stealing
the spotlight from Taylor Swift saying
that Beyonce had the greatest music
video of all time Taylor I'm really
happy for you imma let you finish but
Beyonce had one of the best videos of
all time they remember him for saying on
national television that George Bush
hates black people George Bush doesn't
care about black people to this day
people are still writing blog posts
still making videos still posting out
what a douchebag rude moob that was for
Kanye and well admit yes Kanye does
sometimes step over the line and get
himself in the hot water
nobody really sends Kanye any love to
say thank you for all the great things
that you are doing to think big and make
the world a better place you see we live
in a society where we're afraid to do
things we're afraid of what people will
say we're afraid of people's judgments
we're afraid that we may not make it and
how people will see us if we fail people
aren't so much afraid of the financial
cost of failing they're more afraid of
how people will look at them and judge
them if they do fail I can't tell you
how many people I know who are too
afraid to even put up a single YouTube
video because they're they're afraid of
what people are gonna say about them
when they watch it Kanye West is a doer
he thinks big he acts big he dreams big
and he takes forward progress to go out
and reach his dreams and yes sometimes
he crosses the line and gets himself in
the hot water but I'm tired of people
hating on him pulling up the handful of
moments where he maybe went a little
crazy and spending zero time talking
about the big things that he is doing
and how is impacting the world so Kanye
thank you for being a motivator of the
doers the time is now the time is now to
Express
and for people to believe in themselves
the time is now for it to be okay to be
great
so those are you watching take some time
today to think someone who's got an
impact on your life on your business
somehow make a note make a video pick up
the phone and call them just say thank
you it'll make you feel great then feel
great spread some positive karma and
believe you guys liked this video you
want to see more subscribe to the
channel subscribe to the channel thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
soon if you want more entrepreneur
goodness check out the link to my
newsletter below see you there
you